okay and then what would you do this
weekend malik well
you weren't on the road or you're here i
was in on the road lancaster
where's that uh three hours up from uh
north right yep north
a rave underground underground rave show
oh hold on
yeah so much so many questions okay go
ahead so your manager or whoever booked
this
[ __ ] show was like hey man you know
where lancaster you're like no he's like
yeah say less so here's
that guy it's a rave and we'd love for
you to do some stand-up i've never been
to a rave i was like yeah that sounds
they need a weapon to rave never were
you the only comic
only cop no they had they had three they
had three they had three cards yeah yeah
three comics and
one came with me do you know what a rave
is though yeah
whoa ain't nobody there to hear comedy
no we're all drugged up they're licking
faces
they're [ __ ] people you promise me
hand jobs it's nuts
he didn't promise me that this is like
what he said he said man he saw cause i
performed at the hollywood improv
they're open
again so i did the show he was like hey
bro you know what i love you for i love
your energy
do you want to uh do comedy at a rate
show i was like what is that like
like underground he's like yeah like edm
festivals i was like hell yeah
sounds like a nightmare but he was like
he was like the only thing worse i'm
like hey man you want to
stand up at this funeral tomorrow night
the cemetery it's outside i remember
i do that [ __ ] my jokes be killing them
yeah
so so so he hit me i was like well
what's the crowd like he was like bro
it's gonna be 300 plus people i was like
during kobe he's like yeah they're all a
tentative
trust me you're going to do great now
it's a lot of uh he kept saying ketamine
ketamine yeah he's like there'll be a
lot of academy make jokes about that i
don't even know what that is don't worry
just say it they'll go crazy i said okay
cool so i get there
i was like i'm not driving because you
know i got the sentra i'm not i'm not
yeah yeah
yeah it's not gonna go for three hours
so i was like can i bring
someone i bring my homie give them stage
time and is this a paid
event pay gig cash cash
and pay no yeah yeah it was only two
hundred dollars
no no wait wait wait wait wait but
again but i want more okay so look all
right listen i'm man of the art
so i get there listen we get there at
four o'clock he said he promised me the
promoter
said the show gonna start at six you're
gonna go in right before they start
getting crazy
before brave starts at six it's no the
comedy show starts
oh the comedy oh it goes comedy show
then they're in the rain exactly
okay okay okay get there the promoter is
already on molly every [ __ ] show so he
was like bro i'm sorry
we're not set up we don't have the
speakers we're not set up
no they were still so i get there it's
so many tents it's so
many tents i'm thinking like it's more
than the homeless people like so many
tents
and then there's like hey bro wristband
so they have like two cards right there
you can drive through
they will stop you they'll run down and
stop you like hey bro you didn't check
in
i was like oh [ __ ] so he gave me all all
pass like
wristband get there g nothing
everybody's high
already ready it's ready but it's only
four p.m they've been there since
thursday
i thought it's a raid i didn't know that
so again i'm like okay so i'm going to
put another video of it yeah here we go
right here this is somewhere you're on
stage right
that's no no no no no this is just me
like this looks like the worst gigan
oh my god and then you're trying to do
jokes about it what
so many tits man what the
[ __ ] and you got to do a set i gotta do
a snap
yeah hey
you have no choice but to do crowd work
you can't tell you can't tell no jokes
there no you're a hype man
you're a hype man exactly that's why the
guy was like oh bro you kill him did he
teach you that
they didn't teach you oh yeah so so i i
um this girl who was hula hooping
and she had like lasers she taught me uh
like how to hula hoop with the lights
yeah now was everybody white or i was
only blind
i got two other black guys and they were
darker there to participate they was
like hey bro it's good to see like one
of us
i was like who kidnapped you here i'm
over here
who grabbed y'all shitty get out two
movies
showing the tip chin chilling while i
was in this so the stage is outside
it's like so many so what that dudes on
that's not what you were wrong no
this is why i was performing now i'm in
this game
yeah you did it first of all people are
turned around
people got their backs if you zoom in
zoom in i'm sorry is this the set from
batman forever
i said that it's poison ivy batman
forever
google batman forever poison ivy
dude just in gas you it was half of in
gas
oh my gosh yeah
that's a batman batman named robin uh
with george clooney yeah you're right
when they what today's
yeah that's right no this this is when
val kilmer was batman oh right
yeah that was great oh no that was uh
george clooney
[Laughter]
this girl look at the [ __ ] i know that's
a great reference
so um how many people are in there bro
it's so many people it looks like
there's so many people in the back so
it's like four
tenths combined you know what i would
have done i would have got up there like
oh this is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show someone
gave me a bunch of xc and i would just
had a bunch of sex well
what so at the end and collect my two
hundred dollars yeah then
you wouldn't get the [ __ ] i need to get
for 200 bro and then pomoda took so
uh like a long time to pay you because
soon as i got off the stage they it was
an orgy in that room right now yeah
they called it the cuddle puddle yeah
because it looks like people are sitting
on pillows
they're waiting to [ __ ] they're waiting
to [ __ ] they're waiting they're like yo
bro if you're like
[Applause]
i wonder what they were thinking
bringing a comic to rape and this girl
right here she was pissing me off cuz
she was on molly the whole time she kept
doing this
yeah i was like stop casting spells and
she put her
you're in their house yeah you're right
she pulled a test out right she pulled
the tiss out [ __ ] yeah
and then they were like bro all right
okay they started
listening
boys have to go up too so they went up
before me i hear a lot so
how much time they ain't [ __ ] they ain't
[ __ ] huh how much time did you know
they hate me 15 minutes but i also don't
say headline at the rave though you know
don't say that but don't say that yeah
because there's no
there's no well i like to think that
like my set
brought everyone together because it was
a couple no she didn't she was so
desperate to get her titties
she pulled them out just
[Laughter]
well they were getting desperate they
were getting you have you ever been to
rave
[ __ ] no i i used to work security for
raves and it's
a [ __ ] night they yeah they go
from 6 p.m to 8 a.m
all night seriously seriously it's a
it's a nightmare wait they go through to
the morning yeah
everyone's malnourished drugged up
dehydrated it was a dude who was asleep
him and his dog would sleep the whole
time and he's like music blasting people
walking over
dog listen and then he the dog had to
get him up he licked him he was like get
off as soon as he got up
he drunk water and he hit the vape i was
like oh this is crazy the vape hit the
vape
i didn't know you can get high off
balloons i go in it was a balloon tent
i'm like oh cool cool
he was like yeah you want to smoke it i
said what the [ __ ] so yo yeah
wait oh like they take the nitrogen yeah
there's like these big ass balloons that
you
get
dog i was like what bro i did not know i
was in
and they were i've never heard of them
dude little nitrogen balloon in a dick
suck
what's up man white dudes massaging
girls with their [ __ ] yeah
hey this i saw your [ __ ] fest bro
that yeah i mean it's way bigger than
that chin i'm talking about way
so they oh yeah it was like they were
sitting like they had a balloon tint
and everyone is sitting like that it's
like basically it just gets you high
you lose those things high yeah and they
had like this big ass nitrogen pumping
the dude was like
whip it it's a bad idea and i'm talking
about bro in a tent
hi oh you want to just play with your
voice
yeah have you all been to a ranch and
you've been a rave yeah of course
cat you've been a rapper yeah i've been
raised yeah y'all been around
raves are like a very asian thing now i
saw a lot of them out there
yeah i saw asians and whites like 2000
and
i think eight or nine that there was
like a huge
movement with asians going to rapes i
don't know what it is but like asians
love it
but it's strictly edm music
that song i remember a guy was on lsd
everybody united and started singing
and they just started i'm like god man
they're living it was lit i was like i
need to learn that song but that is
something
so that music is going on that whole
time because you said they go from like
yeah the whole time that's nonsense but
how do dj
they didn't turn the music off i'm a big
fan of [ __ ] music but i don't know if
i get drugs
with drugs yeah i think like you hear
something slightly different
when you're on ecstasy and then you hear
that type of music like it does
something to you like your
uh brain or your wavelength it just yeah
like you feel it more
mm-hmm that's right i've done ecstasy i
have not yeah
i think you know yeah yeah yeah what
yeah
oh my bad we assumed my bad dog i bet
you're recovering
alcoholic and we assume you just dabbled
in eggsy
hey how dare you man no no i bet you in
the 12 step bro
hey you know that's where i get
disrespected
just [ __ ] it hey you know what somebody
i told my girl i'd be home around nine
no
because cause the show started at six
i'll be home around like nine i didn't
get home to like three a.m
are you serious were people all dressed
up and [ __ ] bro everything so
usually the girls that's pretty easy i
got one at 10 30.
you got on that 10 30. yeah and it was
like guys
i can't believe you agreed to that for
two hundred dollars i i know i should
have called
okay i'm sorry two hundred dollars and
you gotta drive three howard well i i
had the guys so you said a lot of a lot
of whites and asians go
whites and asians like angry like asian
yeah white nation usually yeah and
look how they're dressed yeah but it was
way more provocative it's a real [ __ ]
fest
raving is really popular over in europe
too that's where edc
uh like the really big edies yeah yeah
and then we have we have burning man
here yeah it's a little similar
but the girls at burner man are fighting
look at the little breakfast is terrible
she's irish she's uncomfortable
she had too much to cover up she didn't
really want to do it
yo so so the drugs make people want to
[ __ ] then molly don't
so everyone's on molly you want to touch
things yeah so when i get off stage
that's how they greeted you
this is how they greeted me when they
got on stage so i was killing it they
was like oh my god they did the jamie
foxx rub like you oh yeah you killed it
i was like this is when this covet tent
and you over here touching my chest yeah
don't you [ __ ] about coving bro it was a
cuddle puddle so next thing you know
this is how i started like a cuddle
puddle this is how the orgy started so
did you stay and watch the
orgy yeah i would have yeah i ain't
gonna lie to you so no comments by the
way
so they they started kissing and then
like the leader of the tit
started kissing and next you know the
girls like he was a magician
and girl slowly just started like he was
making out with every one of them that
other guys came
combined i'm right there to open it i'm
watching this go down and he was like he
had his hat on and he was just
did this man [ __ ] bro it was like it was
fire and it's crazy at the same time
they started chugging them off yeah they
started sucking them off and then i got
dru
i got grabbed but you got into it no i i
pulled back i was like
i got you're sober yeah i'm sober yeah
because yeah if you're sober that's got
to be weird
it's weird and they had like lights and
you saw the trees you saw the plants
yeah
he was just like a god to them yeah
that's what i'm saying like for you to
handle that
like yeah i mean i went to a space they
had dogs out there too the dogs
had he was [ __ ] oh he was yeah he had
looked other dogs in there lebron is a
cuddle puddle
it's real tall the dog was on molly i
think honestly bro he was licking
everything
all that for 200.
when it all then you gotta pay your boys
it cost you seventy five dollars do you
gotta get snacks on the way home
like really stopping chick-fil-a oh my
god dude i'm not i'm not bill i can't
stay up that late
no that's that's not tough i can't
there's no there's no gig in the world i
can stay up that late no it's just not
the god i mean when i lived in
louisville like the bars closed at four
and i thought
i thought i couldn't handle it but then
i was like oh i like alcohol
i handle it alcohol let you get you oh
yeah you you it's like in vegas when
like you go into that after after
partying like
no what are you gonna do at five in the
morning
are you not exhausted what can we do
like oh everyone's on cocaine that makes
sense
you like you have fun but you're not
like never i don't like staying out late
man never have
yeah just [ __ ] they put cocaine they
put molly in the cocaine now
really yeah the girl told you she was
like yo that sounds fantastic
really that's what they just swear to
god his white girl comes out that that
sounds dangerous
she shouts like yo you about to get
twisted dangerously awesome
so cocaine because he is a downer right
no it's molly and uh
what is mine
when you come down from it though it
must be a [ __ ]
real depressed because it releases so
much dopamine that your body doesn't
have any
so then when you're coming down from it
you're just sad panda
but bro it might be worth it
for them lit six hours
she was part of that orgy she was
getting it hell yeah that's
scary cause here's the in the orgy you
didn't have too much to take off you
know the girls are basically naked
yeah so enough weren't that attractive
now they had like two of them there i
was like oh
if i bet the two are just like yeah yeah
yeah the two no no they were with it
they were
really hot girls go to raves yeah no
yeah but it was asian it was
she was working behind like they sell
water beer no food
and they know they sold no one's hungry
no one's on they sold noodles i don't
know why
yeah noodles it was such a weird rave
they had the asian girl selling noodles
two of them she was slanging she was bad
too bro i was like what are you doing
here don't they drink a lot of orange
juice on molly or something like that
that is why you need fluids
there's a lot of water like stuff like
that electrolytes
yeah liquid yeah
[Laughter]
you know it's funny they had a fake ass
doctor there with a stethoscope
and no
i bet you said that at the party and
even the high guy's like
[Applause]
they had a dude out there with a
testosterone you got that testosterone
you got that
it's funnier this way it's funnier this
way yeah the stethoscope um
did he have just that in his dick out no
he was a tent doctor and you know that
guy who didn't wake up since thursday he
was
like he was like they he went up to him
napping hard he pressed this on
he was like just put a blanket over and
that was it that was the only thing
during the origin show
he did not wake up he did not wake up
and the guy i saw the doc he was alright
cool
he didn't participate in the origin but
i saw him get like some hit the doc
you saw get some head yeah the guy that
oh the doctor the doctor yeah
he's out he's at work yeah you look
tired dude bro he's awesome this [ __ ]
was what saturday
bro saturday yeah i didn't really cost
you seventy five dollars to do that
yeah i was like yeah you had to you had
to pay out the homies
you said one dude wasn't a comic nah nah
so so it gets there that's how we
started the show
so again everyone's jumping jumping in
the main stage so the tent is right
there by the main stage outside it's
cold as hell in the desert
by the way i wore jordans i was like oh
and we're in the sand
dirt i was like bro you had to give me
some new shoes so i uh i wore my homies
shoes and i was like bro
he wore his hiking boots so we we're the
tennis next to the stage
he goes the dj goes everyone's turning
up he's like you're going to see the
best comic in the world he's in the tent
right now the show starts at five
minutes
i was like yes he did on the stage
i was like who is this guy i want to
sound like a weird setup
yeah right next and they look they
didn't stop playing music so i had to do
comedy
next to someone who's just partying so
you hear like edm music and just
it's just not for the space for comedy
yeah for 75
people trying to get their dick sucked
you're out here slaying jokes
i turned i'm like girl can you pay
attention she pulls the tits out
not bad how about that when i get off
stage at the lab factory right away you
go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son